our first knowledge of daiwan dates from
Jung Chen a native of Han Chung in the
south of shenshi Province at that time
the son of Heaven made inquiries among
those of the Shang new who had
surrendered and been made prisoners and
they all reported that the shangnu had
overcome the king of the UAG and made a
drinking vessel out of his skull the UAG
were hiding somewhere constantly
scheming how to Revenge themselves on
the shung new the Chinese wishing to
declare war on the Huns to wipe them out
when they learned this desired to
establish contact with UAG but the road
to them LED through the territory of the
Huns
the emperor called for volunteers Jung
Chen responded to the call and enlisted
in a mission to seek out the UAG he took
with him Kung Fu a Tata who had been a
slave of the tongi family and set out
from kansu to cross the border into Han
territory when Zhang Chen started on his
journey he had more than a hundred men
in his Caravan thirteen years later only
two had lived to return
having marched many days to the West he
arrived at daruan the inhabitants having
heard of the wealth and fertility of
China had vainly tried to communicate
with it when therefore they saw Junction
they asked joyfully where do you wish to
go since that time the UAG had conquered
darsha and occupied the country it was a
rich and fertile land seldom harassed by
robbers and the people decided to enjoy
this life of Peace after having made his
way through so many tribes to find
darsha Zhang Chen was unable to persuade
the UAG to move against their former
enemy he remained there for a year
of the countries he had visited
personally Jung Chen gave this report to
the emperor daruan is to the southwest
of the Huns and Due West of China at a
distance of about 10 000 Lee
circled and engage in agriculture in
their fields they raise rice and wheat
they have wine made of grapes and many
good horses they have walled cities and
houses for large and small cities
belonging to them their arms consist of
bows and hellbirds and they can shoot
arrows while on horseback
darsha is more than 2000 Lee to the
southwest of fergana on the South Bank
of the oxus the people have fixed abodes
and live in Walled cities and regular
houses like the people of daiwan they
have no great king or chief but
everywhere the cities and towns have
their own Petty Chiefs while the people
are shrewd Traders their soldiers are
weak and afraid to fight
the population of darshan May amount to
more than a million to the southeast of
it is the country of India India may be
several thousand lead to the southeast
of bactria the people there have fixed
abodes and their Customs are very much
like those of darsha but the country is
low damp and hot
the people ride on elephants to fight in
battle
the son of Heaven on hearing all this
reason thus daiwan and the possessions
of darsha and parthya are large
countries full of rare things with a
population living in fixed abodes and
given to occupations somewhat identical
with those of the Chinese people but
with weak armies and placing great value
on the rich produce of China
on his return to China Zhang Chen was
appointed great traveler or head of the
office of Foreign Affairs
thank you
China would eventually come West almost
a thousand years later only to be
stopped in the Battle of talas by the
Abbasid Empire losing upwards of 50 000
men cultural contact often leads to
conflict and so our sponsor today is War
Thunder the most comprehensive vehicle
combat game out there and won that
transports you back in time across the
20th century with a wide choice of more
than 2 000 incredibly detailed tanks
planes helicopters and ships to cause
Mayhem with it's available on PC Xbox
series X and S PS5 and previous
generations and it has scalable realism
perfect for wild fun or in-depth
simulation I have personally been
enjoying immersing myself in the
different time periods and the hundreds
of different customizations on offer for
vehicles join me as I accidentally sync
my battleships and receive a free bonus
pack with a premium account Vehicles
boosters and lots more by clicking the
link in the description thanks to War
Thunder for supporting history content
on YouTube
[Music]
now torval made ready for his voyage
with 30 men and took counsel thereupon
with life his brother
they made their ship ready and put to
Sea and nothing is told of their Voyage
until they came to Finland there they
laid up their ship and spent a pleasant
winter and called fish for their support
but in the spring said torvald they
should make ready the ship and that some
of the men should take the ships a Long
Boat around the western part of the
island and explore there during the
summer they found neither dwellings of
men nor beasts except upon an island to
the westward where they found a corn
shed of wood but the next summer when
torwald Eastward with the ship
they sailed away around the Eastern
shores of the land and into the mouths
of the firths which lay nearest there
too and to a point of land there they
came too with the ship and shoved a
plank out to the land and torvald went
up to the country with all his
companions he then said here it is
beautiful and here I would like to raise
my dwelling
then they went to the ship and saw upon
the Sands within the Promontory three
elevations and so there three skin boats
and three men under each they then
divided their people and called them all
except one who got away with his boat
they killed the other eight and then
went back to the cape and looked around
them and saw some Heights inside of the
frith and supposed these were dwellings
after that so greater drowsiness Came
Upon them that they could not keep awake
and they all fell asleep then came a
shout over them so that they all awoke
let us set the shout wake thou torval
and all thy companions if thou will
preserve life returns out of thy ship
with all thy men and leave the land
without delay then rushed out from the
interior of the frith an innumerable
crowd of skin boats and made towards
them Torvalds said then we will put out
the battle screen and defend ourselves
as well as we can but fight little
against them
so did they and the squalings shot at
them for a time but afterwards ran away
each as fast as he could then asked
torvald his men if they had gotten any
wounds they answered that no one was
wounded I have gotten a wound under the
arm said he and here is the arrow and it
will prove a mortal wound to me now
Council I ye that ye get ready instantly
to depart but ye shall bear me to that
Cape where I thought it best to dwell
there shall ye bury me and set up
crosses at my head and feet
foreign
died but they did all things according
to his directions and then went away in
the spring they made ready to sail to
Greenland and now could tell great
Tidings to life
IBN fadlan said I also saw the Russia
they had come to trade and had
disembarked at the ital river I've never
seen bodies as nearly perfect as theirs
as tall as palm trees fair and reddish
they were neither tunics nor captains
every man wears a cloak with which he
covers half his body so that one arm is
uncovered they carry axes swords and
daggers and always have them to hand
they use Frankish swords with broad
ridged blades they are dark from the tip
of their toes right up to their necks
trees pictures and the like
they are the filthiest of God's
creatures they have no modesty when it
comes to defecating or urinating and do
not wash themselves when intercourse
puts them in a state of ritual impurity
they do not even wash their hands after
eating indeed they are like roaming
asses they arrive more their boats by
the ital and build large wooden houses
on its banks they share a house in
groups of 10 and 20 sometimes more
sometimes fewer they are accompanied by
beautiful female slaves for trade with
the merchants they have intercourse with
their female slaves in full view of
their companions they must wash their
faces and their heads every day with the
filthiest and most polluted water you
can imagine let me explain every morning
a female slave brings a large Basin full
of water and hands it to her master he
washes his hands face and hair in the
water then he dips the comb in the water
and combs his hair then he blows his
nose and spits in the Basin he is
prepared to do any filthy impure act in
the water when he is finished the female
slave carries the Basin to the man next
to him who performs the same routine as
his comrade she carries it from one man
to the next and goes around to everyone
in the house every man blows his nose
and spits in the Basin and washes his
face and hair
they disembark as soon as their boat
stock each carries bread meat onions
milk and alcohol to a large block of
wood set in the ground
piece of wood has a face on it like the
face of a man it is surrounded by small
figurines placed in front of large
blocks of wood set in the ground he
prostrates himself before the large
figure and says Lord I have come from a
distant land with such and such a number
of female slaves and such a such a
number of sable pelts he lists all his
merchandise then he says and I have
brought this offering he leaves his
offering in front of the piece of wood
saying I want you to bless me with a
rich Merchant with many Dinars and
durhams who will buy from me whatever I
wish and not haggle over any price I set
when one of them Falls ill they pitch a
tent far away and lay him down inside
with some bread and water they do not
approach him or speak to him indeed they
have no contact with him for as long as
he is ill especially if he is a social
inferior or a Slave
if he recovers and gets back on his feet
he rejoins them if he dies they set fire
to him
they do not bury dead slaves but leave
them as food for the dogs and the birds
I was told that they set fire to their
Chieftains when they die sometimes they
do more so I was very keen to verify
this then I learned of the death of an
important man when the deceased is poor
they build a small boat for him Place
him inside and burn it when he is Rich
they collect his possessions and divide
them into three portions one third goes
to his household one-third is spent on
funeral garments and one-third is spent
on the Alcohol his female slave is
cremated with her master
they are addicted to alcohol they drink
it night and day sometimes one of them
dies Cup in hand
when the chieftain dies all members of
his household ask his female and male
slaves who will die with him one answers
I will at this point the words become
binding there is no turning back it's
not even an option It's usually the
female slaves who offer an injured woman
whom they call the angel of death turns
up she spreads the coverings on the
couch it is her responsibility to sow
The Chieftains garments and prepare him
properly and it is she who kills the
female slaves I saw her myself she was
gloomy and corpulent but neither young
nor old
deceased's nearest male friend comes
forward he picks up a piece of wood and
sets the boat a light
he was completely naked he walked
backwards the nape of his neck towards
the boat his face towards the people he
set fire to the wooden structures under
the boat the people came forward with
sticks and firewood they each carried a
lighted stick that they threw on top of
the wood the wood caught fire then the
boat the yurt the dead man the female
slave and everything else on board
caught fire a fearsome wind picked up
the Flames grew Higher and Higher and
blazed fiercely one of the Russia was
standing beside me I heard him speaking
to The Interpreter who was with me I
asked him what he had said and he
replied he said you Arabs you are a lot
of fools why is that
because you purposefully take your
nearest and dearest and Those whom you
hold in the highest esteem and put them
in the ground where they are eaten by
Vermin and worms we on the other hand
cremate them there and then so that they
enter the Garden on the spot
in the reign of Mikado gonara no in the
108th Emperor since the days of jimmu
sometime around the Koji period a
southern Barbarian trading vessel came
to our Shores from this ship for the
first time emerged an unnameable
creature somewhat similar in shape to a
human being but looking rather more like
a long-nosed Goblin or the giant demon
mikoshi nayudo upon close interrogation
it was discovered that this was a being
called bataren the length of his nose
was the first thing which attracted
attention it was like a conch shell
though without its surface warts
attached by suction to his face his eyes
were as large as spectacles and their
insides were yellow his head was small
on his hands and feet he had long claws
his height exceeded seven feet and he
was black all over only his nose was red
were longer than the teeth of a horse
what he said could not be understood at
all his voice was like the Screech of an
owl one and all rushed to see him
crowding all the roads in total lack of
restraint and all were agreed that this
Apparition was even more Dreadful than
the fiercest of goblins could ever be
though at heart he planned to spread the
karishitan religion he seemed intent
first to survey the wisdom of the
Japanese people he brought with him all
sorts of manner of curious things from
South Barbary
at that time Prince Oda Nobunaga was
Master over the Empire once in the
course of an evening's conversation he
heard tell of that uragan bataran and he
uttered the desire to see the creature
as soon as possible
after two or three days the bataran
appeared before Nobunaga to pay a
basance word had spread that he was
coming to pay a basins to Nobunaga so
the great Lords and lesser Lords of all
Japan minor officials townsmen all
rushed to see the sight you could hardly
push your way through the crowds
for presence he brought 10 muskets
far-seeing and near-seeing spectacles
picture Scrolls medicines goats and
sheep Cathay dogs and many other
artifacts in overwhelming numbers
Prince Nobunaga was not at all
displeased he gave the bataran a plot of
land and a residence and had a colossal
temple built for him
and after that the two bataren called
gariguri and the yarosu were brought
over a native of the province of his end
acted as their Japanese interpreter
well then the Croatia 10 version of
Buddhist Doctrine tells us that at the
time Heaven and Earth were opened up the
one Buddha called Deus as well as the
great Lord made his appearance creating
the Sun and the Moon and Illuminating
the world once he had constructed the
terrestrial domain he let men live there
in opulence but he did not give man
specific instruction on doing good or
doing evil man's Wisdom being but
scanned he offended against deus's law
and for that he is expediently thrust
into
Inferno a place of darkness in the
bowels of the Earth
but they who do not diverge from dose's
teachings fly from here to Paraiso a
place of ease and pleasure in the
heavens above but what is the appearance
of the karishitan temple it contains a
room of mystery in which on display is
an image of deus fashioned in the most
gruesome manner hanging upon a cross
this appears to be a device to extract
tears of emotion from their sectarians
by showing off this figure of Agony and
mortification there is confession to
come into the presence of the Buddha do
Penance and Contrition and pray for
happiness in the future world and in the
back of this room is the meeting room on
display here is an image of the matron
Santa Maria after she gave birth to Deus
holding in her arms an infant in his
second year now the particular
background of this image is as follows
the Buddha called Deus deeming it
unlikely that sentient beings would
themselves learn of Buddha's law or even
of worldly law and certain that they
would doubt the mere statement that he
is the Lord of Heaven and Earth decided
to be born himself into this world and
he caused the womb of Santa Maria to
conceive and to give birth
such is the meeting room and the Chamber
in the back is called the room of
repentance here the bataren and eruman
and all their adherents all sit in a
circle while the penitent in its Center
publicly proclaims Contrition of his
sins and misdeeds begging forgiveness
and subjecting himself to severe
humiliation thereupon the bataren taking
into his hands the aforementioned
penitencia flogs The Sinner causing the
flow of blood and the thing called Cruz
he values as all important all the
profundity have a source's depths also
it would seem
once a fool has turned his ready ear to
something and set his heart to it
nothing will change his mind to use an
analogy a child of two or three and
seeing a reflection in a mirror thinks
it is an actual figure a monkey in
seeing the moon on the surface of the
water tries to grab it with his paws for
such is the Simplicity of their minds
all fools are like that
[Music]
I accompanied Mrs farewell Flynn and
several Seaman with about 40 natives on
a journey to King Chaka of the Zula
Nation on the eighth day after having
traveled about 135 miles through a most
picturesque country and crossed several
Rivers we arrived at the summit of a
mountain from which The View was
particularly Grand and imposing we could
distinguish the king's residence and
numerous other crawls on extensive plane
encompassed by a chain of hills
shortly afterwards we came to a brook
where we refreshed and put ourselves in
proper apparel to meet the king a
domestic now informed us that the King
was holding an N daba with his Warriors
we then proceeded in order and soon
discovered his majesty and his court
surrounded by large fires we stood for a
few minutes while the chief who
accompanied us addressed the king
relative to our mission after this we
were desired to advance presented our
presence and seated ourselves on the
ground about six Paces from him during
this interview his discourse was
principally on war owing to his enemies
being at hand he shortly afterwards
dismissed his people and retired to his
private crawl we then received a message
requesting that we would wait upon him
there
here our reception was very different
from the former he Now cast off his
stern look becoming good humored and
conversed with us through our
interpreters on various subjects a large
basket of boiled beef and several
Earthen pots of milk were ordered to be
placed before us of which we ate
heartily
in the evening we were highly
entertained by his Warriors singing War
and other songs that the King's request
we fired a train of powder to show its
effects
thank you
the following morning proved exceedingly
hot so much so that it was scarcely
possible to stir about we therefore kept
within our Hut the king however feeling
no inconvenience from it sent for our
Sailors and proposed they're going with
him and a number of his people to hunt
the elephant
these men being aware of their inability
and having only lead on balls prudently
declined saying they could not go
without consulting us
the king desired The Interpreter to tell
them they were afraid this touched their
pride of the insufficiency of our arms
of which we were equally aware to
destroy such animals
we immediately went in pursuit of them
and soon fell in with the King
surrounded by his Warriors sat under a
large tree from which he had a complete
view of the valley out of which they
intended to start the elephant we took
our station about 200 yards from him
under a smaller tree waiting impatiently
yet dreading the result
two hours had nearly elapsed when a
messenger presented to the king the tale
of an elephant at which they all
appeared greatly surprised and said the
white people had killed the animal as
maybe supposed we could scarcely credit
the fact but hastened towards the forest
to join our people and met them almost
exhausted it appeared that the natives
drove the elephant from the forest to a
plane where the sailors placed
themselves directly before the animal
the first shot entered under the ear
when it became Furious the other lodged
near the four shoulder after which it
fell and soon expired and this affair
turned out differently we should in all
probability have been held in a
contemptible light by this nation and
awkward consequences might have resulted
to the settlement
foreign
[Music]
in the evening in request of the king we
joined in their amusements and could not
ourselves avoid singing
we commenced with God Save the King on
our explaining its literal meaning Chaco
was highly pleased in fact there was
nothing but good humor to be observed in
the countenance of everyone present
the party broke up at a late hour and as
is usual in the morning we paid the king
an early visit we now expressed a wish
to see him in his War dress he
immediately retired and in a short time
returned a tired his dress consists of
monkey skins in three folds from his
waist to the knee from which two white
cow's Tales are suspended as well as
from each arm round the head is a neat
band of fur stuffed in front of which is
placed a tall feather and on each side a
variegated plume he Advanced with his
shield and oval about four feet in
length and an um konto or spear when his
Warriors commenced a war song
tracker is about 38 years of age upwards
of six feet in height and well
proportioned
while sitting in our heart at a late
hour we were aroused by the shrieks of
thousands of human voices that we
naturally concluded With the Enemy
advancing being aware they expected them
hourly the real cause however was soon
ascertained which was the death of the
king's grandmother supposed to be
between 90 and 100 years of age men
women and children having cried bitterly
for several hours they're ensued a
profound silence after which thousands
of the same moment commenced a most
doleful song which lasted a night and
the greater part of the following day it
is said that this is the only instance
ever known of the king having grieved
the day arrived for our departure
tracker made us a present of 107 head of
cattle we then took our leave with a
promise of returning as early as
possible
remember to follow the link in the
description to dive into the chaotic
World of War Thunder and enjoy over a
hundred years of vehicles clicking the
link will also give you premium vehicles
and boosters
foreign